i'm a huge fan of wedding crashers  and i heard that there's a script for  the sequel that maybe you guys have read  so i'm curious what did you think of  reading the script  yeah there is a script and david dobkin  has  who directed of course the first one has  been working on it  and uh we've been talking about it and  uh  it's been nice talking to vince um and  it's one of those movies that  you know really you know seem to connect  with people so  if if we can come up with a um  you know something we think could be  great then uh then i'm sure we'll do it  there's a lot of rumors you guys might  be filming it this year do you think  it's actually gonna happen  i i someone said august and i don't see  that happening  um but um i think it's you know  before anything it was sort of you know  making sure that  everybody felt we had a great story